our final final presenter Julie Brown
will be joining us next
she is program director of Justice
Resource Institute integrated clinical
services she is a behavioral tech
trainers which means that she does
training for in DBT for the group that
was developed by Marsha Linehan so she
still works in that capacity with Marsha
Linehan she is the author of the skill
system which is a modified DBT emotion
regulation skills curriculum designed
for children adolescents adults who have
learning challenges we'll be hearing a
lot about that skills system she
provides consultation on that system in
the US Canada and Europe she is the
recipient of the American Association on
intellectual and developmental
disabilities Leadership Award I would
like to highlight that I think one theme
of this conference is not getting too
attached to our labels our methods and I
think that what we're gonna hear about
in in julie brown's work is very
exciting because she saw a population
where if we hung too closely to what
works we wouldn't reach it there was
need for flexibility and change and we
got to i think we'll see some real
creativity of how to reach people who
otherwise would not be served we have to
take them where they are and i think
that that what she put together really
speaks to that so i'm very excited to
have her and in terms of dealing with
individuals helping individuals with
intellectual challenges this is really a
perfect end to our day because it really
speak to what are some things you can do
when the issue is that there are
intellectual attentional thinking
difficulties we're gonna see in
operation what this can look like so
thank you very much for joining us Julie
brown
well I'm really honored and really
excited and really cognitively
dysregulated so I'm just I'm being it
for you so myself together like I said
we're gonna talk about some treatment
options for folks with intellectual
disabilities that expose that experience
emotional cognitive and behavioral
regulation problems also and I feel like
I'm representing the treatment options
but it's like batting ninth in this
all-star lineup so thanks for hanging in
here what an incredible day I'm just an
emotional fantastic day um I was
thinking it's really interesting that
I'm here representing the intellectual
disabilities world is related to
treatment because if you think about it
I'm a master's level social worker I'm
presenting to you an emerging practice
that's got pilot data and to be honest
it's about as good as it gets in the
disabilities world at this point so I'm
just so excited that you guys are all
here and just it's like a great big
family bringing everybody on board so
they're thinking about this population
through sort of mainstream means I just
really appreciate that you're all here
I've already made one disclosure I'm a
social worker I'm out about it now I'm
actually just went back to get my PhD
and so I'm almost like a born again
social worker I talked about
marginalization and all that stuff and I
actually believe it now code of ethics
term I my real code but the other real
disclosure is about the fact that we are
going to talk about the scale system it
really is a treatment tool it is not an
evidence-based practice at this time
it's a set of strategies that's really
in its infancy really was developed
through practice with my clients
collaboratively so I just you know I'm
hoping that it improves self-regulation
I mean it's really why I tortured myself
at almost age 50 to go back to school so
that I can actually get
data and learn how to actually use it so
that's something I got to coordinate all
this so let's just okay I did it
use this Oh forward backward and a laser
oh goodness
okay more cognitive dysregulation okay
so I figured um I talked to Seth about
it and originally I was just gonna talk
about the skill system but he and I
chatted a bit and decided it might be
interesting for you folks to the folks
might be interested in learning a little
bit about improving accessibility of DBT
for folks with intellectual challenges
so I thought we'd start there and then
move into learning how to be skills
masters ourselves so hopefully you'll
actually walk away with a few treatment
ideas but I think before we get started
I've got this down that's for sure I'll
tell you a little bit about my program
I've worked for about 20 years now in
Rhode Island and I've got treating
individuals with intellectual
disabilities and very serious or acutely
dysregulated behavioral challenges it is
part of justice Resource Institute it's
a very small program and what we do is
we provide individual DBT therapy but we
combine it with the skill system for the
skills training component I'll talk a
little bit about how we got there in a
couple of minutes but people with
intellectual disabilities as well as all
the folks that we've already been
talking about today are at increased
vulnerability people with intellectual
disabilities have much higher rates of
victimization over three times as much
they're also at higher risk for mental
health issues as well as experiencing
what they call in the field is
challenging behaviors and I think that's
kind of interesting so the rates are
very diverse on this from 10 percent up
to 85 percent are some numbers around
and how many people exhibit challenging
behaviors
unfortunately there's not much treatment
that's empirically validated out there
for this particular population of folks
that are really dually diagnosed with
mental health and intellectual
disabilities ABA is a tool that is used
in some populations of disabilities but
it's not generally used as much with
adults living in community-based
settings that are in the mild
intellectual disabilities range due to
feasibility issues and consistency
additionally there's some research about
CBT that looks pretty good unfortunately
the methodologies are not fantastic as
well as the measures people are using
are more staff reports and and these
like looking at hypothetical situating
hypothetical situations there's very
little with actual behavioral data that
looks at generalization of skills which
is really the main concerned with this
population which is how do we get them
to generalize into the context of their
lives so you go farm unfortunately there
aren't many silver bullets out there for
this group as well things like
diagnostic overshadowing there's a lot
of side effects the communication
problems with the clients unfortunately
there's not really great data either way
on that as well now although there's not
a lot of actually they were I just was
looking up neurofeedback I thought that
was so cool there are a few small
studies for that I don't know much about
them but they could be worth looking at
for sure
but there really isn't much data around
adapting DBT for this population there
are a few small studies but if you think
about it DBT is really built to treat
sort of ingrained reinforce patterns of
emotional cognitive and behavioral
self-regulation problems and this
population experiences those and it's a
comprehensive multimodal treatment and
this population really needs that so at
first blush it's a it's a great fit I
actually I'll disclose also that I fell
in love with DBT in 1997 I was working
a residential school half voice half
girls that had that were duly diagnosed
with intellectual disabilities and
mental health issues and it was a fiasco
there it was a you know it was a very
challenging environment I had no idea
what I was doing straight out grad
school and when Stanford you know the
trauma expert said to me you want to go
check out this DBT it's for like
suicidal women and have something oh
that's a great application for me that's
just gonna dump tail perfectly but I
went there and I kind of as I was
desperate so I went oh this is gonna be
and Heidi heard started talking about
the biosocial theory and and Marcia's
you know it framework for emotional
dysregulation and it was like everything
just came clear to me I was like angels
were singing and I was like here's
talking about the kids that I'm dealing
with with intellectual disabilities and
so it was really a starting point for me
I then harassed my boss for the next two
years and was able to get intensively
trained and I remember the moment of
like getting my certificate at the DBT
training I don't know if you guys play
several of you that have gone through
this but she's like dance at the end and
I like actually did a cartwheel and
Cindy and Charlie were there was so
psyched and such a loser but I was
pumped no seriously and I'm like I'm
going back to Rhode Island and I'm gonna
be adherent
is I don't want to make margin mad
alright
no I the marshal looks like my mother
but that's a whole nother I'm not going
there for this room I'm not going there
so anyway so I the good news was that I
found that really let's go to the next
little slide I found it you know maybe
it's a stretch maybe I'm just used to
dealing with this population but the fit
for individual therapy was not a million
Mouse off I felt like I could definitely
make accommodations that were making
that work and it was really an important
part of what I saw the is what was
effective about DBT for this group the
skills on the other hand was a little
bit of a challenge and we'll get into
that a little bit more um so you you are
you may not be treating people with
intellectual disabilities and when I say
intellectual disabilities the people
that I treat have IQs between about 45
and 70 so we're talking folks that have
very very limited intellectual
capacities very very but not like
they're pretty but everybody is verbal
that I deal with but they definitely
have very impaired learning capacities
so you probably you may not be treating
that I know I have bumped into some
folks that are treating folks with
disabilities you may not be treating
them and you may also not be using DBT
but I hope as we talk maybe you can just
you know find a few helpful hints in
this about dealing with people with
serious learning vulnerabilities so the
folks that I deal with definitely
reading and writing is a barrier and so
instead we use communication sheets in
conjunction with the diary cards and the
diary cards are really secondary it's
very important when we do the behavior
analysis part of DBT with this group
especially people that are exhibiting a
lot of stage one high end behaviors that
we have good information so that we can
really do the behavior and solution
analysis because folks that have recall
problems in memory and executive
functioning and sequencing problems it's
really hard to get a clear picture
within the time that we have for
individuals there
we use a lot of written forms which is
sort of ironic but we read them too we
sort of you make sure that we read it
read things to people and things like
informed consent we take a lot of time
on that because folks with intellectual
disabilities that have you know been in
the system for a long time it's you know
it's their sense of identity and their
sense of their sort of over compliance
sometimes in the system is really
prevalent and so we take a lot of time
to make sure that they really are
interested and doing engaging in this
relationship so that's a little bit more
pronounced all the DBT strategies we use
by the book with when we'll talk about
the the the quickstep assessment helps
make the adjustments and that's actually
the next thing we're going to talk about
but the stages the hierarchies
validation contingencies I think what we
do a lot more of though is orientation
because folks with disabilities have a
hard time with transitions and so
helping orient people the shifts in the
treatment shifts in the conversation and
in the focus and orienting to what what
is going on is a really useful tool
like I said behavior analysis is
impacted by people's memory and
sequencing capacities it's a slower
process we definitely use a lot more
visuals to sort of chart out finding the
doing the chain analysis treatment
itself has a longer time frame and like
I said we had to change the
accessibility to the skills folks that
have been that had these issues and have
trauma issues have a hard time with
novelty and so and and have a difficulty
like I said with transitions and so I
think that has to be sort of in the
forefront of our mind developmental
issues actually we talked about
behavioral treatment planning I think
that you know it definitely is a part of
the treatment but it really does have to
be negotiated with the person carefully
just applying I've talked to certain
people
feel like you just intensify behavioral
treatment planning but that's just you
can't use that as a broad brushstroke it
really is a process with getting the
person integrated into the process so
that they so yeah they're not just
getting acted upon by the environment
that there are actually collaborators in
that and that's an important issue when
we're dealing with these folks sometimes
there's a lot of polarization between
staff and and the consumer and DBT is
wonderful because it really creates an
egalitarian sort of playing field where
it's not sort of I'm smarter than you
you're you're you know you're not so
there's that there's no fewer power
struggles and for this population it's
really important to really clearly
define this as inegalitarian
relationship and that's really that
allows that identity that we've been
talking about today just to begin to
sort of be mobilized and that's a big
part of what the skill system is about
is sort of engaging that sort of
identity okay
ebrill Trina I talked about that okay we
also do integration of services so we do
wraparound supports I have to say it's
really challenging sometimes to get
teams to function as skills coaches and
we get into a lot of systems work within
the agencies and I think that's sort of
one of those things that sounds really
easy well we'll just train staff to be
skills coaches sometimes it's just
really difficult and that's it's really
one of the next things I'd like to
master if I possibly could okay all
right the quickstep assessment is
something that we developed i actually
developed as just it's really just a
common-sense tool it's based on on the
work of sweller with the cognitive load
theory and it just I had to transfer the
idea of what it's like to sit with a
person with intellectual disabilities
and make the adjustments that have that
we have to do when we're trying to
create an intervention so the first step
is to to assess the cognitive load of
the intervention and we'll talk about
that in just one minute the second step
is to evaluate where the person is at in
that moment with their level of
cognitive regulation and the third is to
make the changes that you need
- in the in the intervention we just go
over this one quick quote from sweller
about this cognitive load theory is a is
concerned with the learning of complex
cognitive tasks in which learners are
often overwhelmed by the number of
interactive information elements that
need to be processed simultaneously
before meaningful learning can commence
I just love this next this bit of
information that he gives us so these
are the these are the elements that
increase cognitive load and and that
impacts people's learning capacities and
their ability to process information so
when there's simultaneous processing of
information or new information or high
volume of information or interactivity
of information retrieval of divergent
information rapid shifts without
transition from one topic to another
strong emotional responses to
information and strong emotion and
strong emotional responses to the
intervention so pretty much everything
increases cognitive flow so what do we
do what we what are we so step two so
it's just paying attention when you're
going to be doing something is what I'm
doing going to increase cognitive load
it's really important for us to be
proactive and understanding that what
we're doing is going to be part of the
transaction with this consumer / this
client and so we really have to be
mindful of what we're asking them to do
and which things on this is it going to
be triggering cognitive dysregulation
okay so what do so then we start looking
for as we're moving through an
intervention we want to see how
somebody's reacting to it do we say
signs of confusion are they becoming
unfocused is there some sort of avoidant
looking behavior are they experiencing
discomfort or what might look like well
willfulness or resistance and some of it
that resistant client I'm sure sometimes
has to do with the fact that we haven't
designed things properly and that people
are just having a really hard time with
what we
decided to talk about and how we're
doing it so here are just some ideas
about things you can do in that moment
when you start seeing those signs of
when people are dysregulated we can try
to simplify the concepts you can do a
task analysis sometimes that's a common
problem is that we don't see like how
many steps are in something and like
they get jammed up on one of the early
steps and worse we kind of in our minds
are oversimplifying how to get there we
don't see that there are some
intermediate you know processes that are
going on that they're not they're not
able to transition through worked
examples kind of give people the right
answers
don't make them have to go and search
sometimes so showing them how to do it
correctly through like modeling is is
helpful shaping obviously of
interventions validating the person's
experience positive reinforcement and
then contingency management just sort of
letting people know sort of how they're
doing okay great
all right so I here's the cover of the
book and it's called the skill system
instructors guide and in this present
the skill system and it's got like all
the all the curriculum materials you'd
ever need and you can you can get it
through Amazon for like 29 bucks it's
it's a really inexpensive set of very
comprehensive tools for people and so
let's just take a second to look at our
data our little pilot data that Milton
Brown did with me thank God because he's
a fantastic statistician we had an N of
40 of folks with intellectual
disabilities that were at ICS for at
least one year they all demonstrated
challenging behaviors their IQs or the
mean was about a 59 something and then
and the I cute like I said that was the
I kid in the ages the mean was 36
everybody also had a mix of mental
health disesteem I got to put that in
here but notice there is no control
group so it's not an experimental design
we broke it down into three levels of
risk
red-flag behavior is like low-risk sort
of non-compliant behavior dangerous
situations just like threatening
behavior and then laughs behaviors are
sort of really sort of violent
aggressive or problematic behaviors that
break the law we looked at demographic
information we took behavioral outcomes
over a four year period there's a lot of
data in the disability system because
people when they have a behavioral a
treatment plan you have to you do a lot
of tracking of behaviors so we're really
fortunate that way that is one of the
strengths of the study and it was long
it was longitudinal in it was four years
we used the repeated measures design and
some hierarchy when a linear modeling
for some of the associations we did see
if you can see that well the data looks
pretty good I mean so um where to pick
up four numbers um so the red flag
behaviors came down really quickly in
the first year with this combo
individual DBT and skills training down
to a point zero zero one significance of
change and in the dangerous situations
was a point zero zero three level of
significance and then in laps behaviors
and so you can see that and it's really
kind of interesting here they're in
dangerous situations that come and goes
up although not significantly but it
goes up a little bit as the lapses go
down that kind of cool that's gonna say
to me all right that's threatening and
they're not doing so that's just kind of
cool but I love this sort of trajectory
they're on the laps behavior where it
comes down then it kind of doesn't
significantly go up but Italy goes up
and I kind of see that as that sort of
adolescent I'm all that and a bag of
chips I'm trying to get my you know I'm
kind of working with my team like it's
and it goes down further eventually and
that's at the four year mark and so I
think that's sort of it's one of the
fewer articles that's impressed right
now with the Journal of mental health
research and into like in intellectual
disabilities but it really does sorta
for the first time talk about the fact
that the treatment needs to be longer
for this group
so the design of the skill system well
talked a little bit about it and this
may be relevant for what we've already
talked about today a little bit so the
skill system is built as a series of
skills that are over learned to help
span the duration of an emotion Marsha
talks about sort of a slow return to
baseline on an emotion and a lot of
times if folks are just using like a
single a single skill application what
we're looking for is really spanning the
entire experience and we talked today
also about the ability to be in the
present moment you know when someone
doesn't have any regulatory capacities
and an emotion can be a very hot hot
difficult thing and so it we really are
working to increase self-awareness in
the moment and being able to be in the
present as it is it makes me think of
you know I I think about my clients that
what it's kind of like you know one of
those movies where the guys running
through the jungle and he's got the
machete and the bad guys are chasing and
he's coming and then and he and the girl
are there and they get up to the the
chasm like that and they stop and it's
like oh my god they almost fall over and
they look and they look up and what do
they see they see a bridge but that
ain't a good bridge is it it's never a
good bridge it's like a vine and a piece
of metal and like one piece of wood and
they're like holy what are we gonna do
so so that's kind of what I noticed with
my clients is that they're they're
running and they stop and they just
don't have the skill and this sort of is
so them stepping through an emotion
where they have to stop and say they
just don't have the skill to get across
it so we stopped and so what I'm hoping
in theory the skill system really is
about them placing boards in that bridge
so that as many as necessary to spin
across that entire experience and and be
having the capacity to do that to be
able to assemble their own skill chains
helps them manage novel experiences more
effectively so the the skill system is
also as far as cognitive aspects
it's designed to to facilitate
recognition and recall another silly
story i guess i have a lot of those is i
went fishing once of my dad it was a big
day and he usually dragged me out
fishing like long boat rides we've never
caught anything he was he was having a
blast it was torture but this one day he
took me out and he's like we're gonna go
mackerel fishing i don't care alright so
but it was cool about it is on the hook
they were you had the line and there
were six little hooks and what you did
was you put it in and yeah caught six
fish at one time so i'm like why do we
do the other stuff why what's wrong with
mackerel i didn't eat any of it anyway
obviously it's oily anyway but i know is
a bowl was fully beautiful fish anyway
so what's that got to do to the skill
system but it's basically the idea the
design of it is the skill system is
built like that that line of hooks that
once they start it because it's all
connected with the skills that you can
start the process and it all comes out
because it's as folks learn it as a
system and so ok so the other thing is
it's structured as well as flexible and
that's really critical for managing
humanity i think in the disabilities
field it's really common for things to
get oversimplified and kind of dumbed
down I hate that word but it's kind of
use and you'll say well we got a board
game to fix that you know and we're not
looking and sometimes there's also this
misnomer that we're looking at squashing
or repressing emotion getting people
just to be compliant and that that's
what teams are sometimes seeming to look
for that's not what the skills isms
built for it's really to help people
experience a full range of emotion just
like physical therapy getting a full
range of motion of like physical motion
this is about getting the full capacity
to experience joy and strengths and love
and intimacy and making money and you
know doing all the things that sort of
create satisfaction for people it's
important that people with disabilities
have access to that as well and now that
turbulence that is life is important to
have a system that they can actually
navigate that through that wind and you
know I think from all the reactions that
people have from their you know past
experience before therapy you know
there's a lot of ingrained sort of
maladaptive chains of behavior and
ingrained patterns and so what we want
to do is create a system where the
chains of the adaptive capacities and
adaptive skills get really more
reinforced on it actually also by having
this prosthetic and system in place and
it really allows people also to to
engage in contextual learning because it
function it's almost like a prosthetic
or a template for them and so when they
go into context which are very very
complicated when you're a person with
intellectual disabilities this the
situations that they live in are really
complex they the day programs have a lot
of people that have a lot of issues a
lot of behavior problems and you're
dealing with staffing it's it's not an
easy life in a lot of ways and so being
able to learn and utilize something in
that when they're at a very high level
of cognitive dysregulation it's
important that that it's over learned so
that they can then recall it in those
high-stress situations
ok so we're hoping that folks get some
behavioral control by being able to make
effective transitions and like I said
constructing those chains and it's
really helping you know we talked about
navigating and difficulty navigating
with the earlier talks today this really
functions almost like a map for people
you know it helps them manage the
variables they're internal and external
variables in an organized kind of
flexible way so that they can they can
sort of navigate both of those internal
and external environments more
effectively and more consistently the
other thing is the developmental piece
I think Bessel was talking about it's
really cool he said experience itself
the way you are and that really is sort
of how the skill system is built because
the skill system doesn't mobilize a lot
of like this is right this is wrong the
pros and cons the cognitive exhorted
explicit thinking it's really tries to
get at wisdom it tries to get to that
inner voice that inner capacity that all
these people have and its really
mobilizing their strengths not their
weakness and it has a double bang for
the buck because not only is it a
strength but it's also a really
important part of identity development
to really get that sort of sense of self
you know activated in their life context
it also creates you know art in these
systems that creates a common language
between people in group as well as in
their in their group homes and and that
can also expand learning um also gives
people environmental tools to use in
their environments we're talking about
manipulation before it's like no I want
I'm gonna train my guys to be
manipulative they are going to be very
very manipulative they're gonna be
getting what they need from people and
that's really what we really work on
being effective and trying to to manage
these very complicated expansive teams
of people that are supporting them and
so the skill system is an important part
of that okay now enough talking about
that now you have to start remembering
stuff all right there are how many
skills the skill system nine very good
skills masters I love that all right you
guys are good alright um okay so
adapting back to that adapting question
okay so I came back to her down and
after getting trained was really gonna
do it
well the first sign was when the bell
went flying out the window that I said
that's not a great sign and I'm a pretty
good teacher and it wasn't working and
then I just had this sense that I was
actually in fact torturing my client
and I had another you know I was I was
like I was better I was it hearing so
there's a real dialectic there and so I
just kept I had little flashbacks to of
like when I was a kid I had my sister 7
years older and she was wicked cool and
she didn't like me very much which was
kind of made me sad but but every once
in a while I was like twice a year she'd
say to me she'd go so Julie you want to
play cards
I'm like what do I think yeah oh my god
so inside I'm like oh my god my sister
wants a card she thinks I'm so cool
we're gonna be bonding I love this and
she's like yeah 52 pickup like every
time and I get that look every time like
you're like in a movie so it's like I
look down and it's like everywhere and
that's kind of what I mean I look I love
DBT as much as it can be loved but
unfortunately the way that the skills
curriculum is put together it's not
really user friendly telling people sort
of what skills to use when and so I kept
I would I sort of think about 50 to pick
up because that's what my clients they
just didn't have the capacity to draw
things together in these contexts where
they're totally dysregulated and they
have a 45 IQ to boot
so and sometimes the mnemonics are a
little bit challenging alike my favorite
is Elle and please what's L for please
you know treat physical illness with
Elle
oh no I'm sure it's very good no it's
just not hugely intuitive but it's just
it's just me okay now all right let's go
no it's it sounds like Marsha bashing
but it is not Marsha bashing okay
you can't barely read this and I managed
to mess up your handout a little bit so
you have a different version sorry sorry
sorry about that but everything that's
on this you have in your whole little
packet so try not to to get too upset
about that but let's just go through
these so um so these are the nine skills
and you'll notice that we try to get the
language to reflect the action that
we're looking for the person to do so
let's think about what's implicitly
built in to the concept of clear picture
and it's number one for a reason it's
first so what do you think clear picture
well we're gonna say it's probably
clarity right the sense that the first
step is to be aware of your internal and
external experience in the moment and it
just doesn't end there
you know it's it's that's just the the
first element so there are six parts of
it I'll just read through them quickly
this is what you don't have but it is
later okay so the first thing is and
these are not in any particular order
but we basically learn them in order but
the six constant concepts are take a
breath notice your surroundings label I
mean do a body check label and rate
emotion notice your thoughts and notice
your urges okay the point is really to
get a 360 degree view sort of have
outside an inside and we're not talking
about this like oh meditation thing
we're talking about a quick snapshot
that helps you understand where you're
at where everybody else is at my clients
talked about it taking about between two
and three seconds usually to get a clear
picture and they're amazingly good at it
the next one is on track thinking let's
think about what's implied there I'm
very sensitive to the term on track I
hear it everywhere which is a great
thing that's the point right we want to
be mobilizing the common knowledge that
people have that
that are intuitive and so on track
implies a goal potentially and the idea
of thinking and being on track is
thinking that's going to be on track to
your goal now within that there's a few
steps and we'll talk about that but I
just want to prime your memories a
little bit get it in there that first
time the idea is to sort of reflect and
then check remember we had a clear
picture the last step was notice the
urge up there the transition point to on
track thinking is to check the urge and
that checking process
it's thumbs up for an urge that's going
to help you get to your goal and thumbs
down for urges that are not going to get
you to goal and this is where this wise
mind concept or inner wisdom or just
what you think is right in your gut
really it should be down here and you're
good I suppose but I have it near my
heart usually when I do it with my
clients and that's sort of you know and
these guys are really sensitive to what
we want them to do because of some of
the issues around supports and so the
idea of really getting people to sort of
Center down to what it is really that
they want isn't it is is a very
important process and it's hard because
the folks that supporting these people
are pretty traumatized too and so they
tend to kind of rush and unfortunately
that's not overly useful and then starts
power struggle and so really that idea
of taking time to really make this self
evaluation of whether this actions going
to be helpful or not helpful the next
concept of it is turn it and that's sort
of turning it to on track thinking sort
of you know working with sort of off
track not helpful thoughts and turning
it to on track thoughts okay so let's
look at on track action what's implied
they're the same thing we have okay so
we have on track thinking it's thinking
about doing what's on track and then the
the next key part is on track action
which is taking it not you know talks
pretty cheap we've got to be moving it
into action
when I had James gross the editor of the
emotion regulation handbook look at this
material he was terrifically helpful but
he was really stressing the idea of this
this triangle of clear picture on track
thinking and on
tract action really being the core
concepts that are very very important
okay well go kind of quickly through
these so just safety plan pretty obvious
what that's about right that's looking
at how to manage your own sort of
situation in the safe way we'll go into
more detail about that the next one is
Noomi activities that's sort of all the
things you do during the day and will
break down different types of activities
and the different functions that each
one can fit I mean and that gets into
that cognitive regulation emotion
regulation sort of about what you do has
a different impact on your body and on
your emotions and then the
problem-solving that's obvious I'm
expressing myself that's fairly obvious
and something called getting it right is
actually the equivalent of deer man in
and DBT and this is how people get what
they want and this is a very important
skill for this population because they
have so many people to manage and
getting things and they have very few
resources and so they really have to
leverage their capacities very very well
and effectively to get what they need
and the last one is relationship Karen
will talk about that too okay all right
now we've talked a little bit about the
skills and but now okay so you have
skills but the whole point was the time
all together right so we don't we we've
got to talk about the difference so
there are three what we'd call system
tools little guidelines or rules almost
for putting them together and these go
along with the nine skills that they
learn and so the first one here is
called the feelings rating scale and
we'll go to that in a second it's
basically a zero to five scale that we
use to rate emotion hang on let's just
go and the second one is categories of
skills the skills are broken down into
two categories one is calm as one is all
the time skills and the other one is
calm only skills and then the last one
is a recipe for skills so let's just go
through those so this is our feelings
rating scale and it's really not a
feelings rating scale but I couldn't
call it emotional cognitive behavioral
rating scale because that would have
really been like
that would have been not not really a
good term and so we use the feelings
rating scale and basically it's how
folks rate emotions and you remember
when we looked at clear picture a few
minutes ago when it said label and rate
emotions and getting a clearer picture
this is that scale zero to five that
folks use now basically a zero up to
three is the range where people are
basically cognitively regulated
obviously three is a stronger emotion
than a one but basically in that zone
people are able to be effective in
relationships they're able to have what
we would say a two-way street
relationship with they're listening and
they're talking and they're still being
able to be effective once they cross
over from the three into the four zone
that's when the straw it's a stronger
emotion the cognitive dysregulation is
kicking in more as well as the
behavioral dysregulation as well then
the the transition and they're they're
really only able to do one-way street
relationships where either they're
expressing and they're not hearing you
know or vice versa and then a5 there's a
difference between four and five because
of five is when someone is out of
control overwhelmed to the point where
they're hurting self other or property
okay
okay great sorry about that okay here's
here's um now the feelings rating scale
is very important because it helps us
understand what skills that you can use
in the moment and I loved what was it
Gabriela that said strike while the iron
is cold this morning that was great this
is a lot about what this concept is
about it's really about doing certain
skill see the first five skills clear
picture on track thinking on track
action safety plans and Noomi activities
our skills that are really done
independently sort of with the
independently the person with themselves
and you can use those from a zero to
five emotion and so really if the person
is over a three I II really upset these
are the skills that they focus on first
and and the second set which are called
calm only skills which is
problem-solving expressing myself
getting it right in relationship care
you only use zero two three
when you're able to be interactive these
skills are obviously more complex they
involve other people they involve people
saying that word no or maybe which is
really difficult it involves people
having opinions of their own and it that
you need to be very strategic to be able
to use these skills so it's really
important that people are cognitively
regulated emotionally and behaviorally
regulated as well I would have to say
that about ninety nine per no data to
support that a lot behavioral problems
that my folks have are when they're
using their comm only skills when
they're over three they're off very
often they'll come in will do a behavior
analysis and they have given somebody a
piece of their mind
well that's expressing myself or they've
run away well that's kind of like
problem solving and so is you know they
end up sort of trying to get stuff and
they're screaming at people and so it's
getting it wrong instead of get it or
right so those are the kind of things
that that so what I like about it is
that when you are doing behavior and
solution analysis you're really looking
at
that when people you know have target
behaviors during the week it's often a
skill breakdown that it's like that they
just chose the wrong skills that weren't
as effective in that moment and in that
way sort of depersonalized I said a
little bit it's really oh you know and
the idea isn't you know because when
there's trying to do safe
problem-solving areas a commonly skill
those skills are really really important
for this population because you know
they've got to be able to be activated
and manage themselves in their
environment so it's not that that we
don't want them I don't want them doing
problem solving it's just what you
wanted to is do the other skills first
until your level of escalation comes
down a little bit and you're able to
step back and then engage in in the in
the skill when you're going to be
effective at it and so it really builds
in some delay at that point it doesn't
it doesn't mean not do it okay and the
last one we saw we've got our feelings
so we've got that first two tools are
your feelings rating scale zero to five
we've got our categories of skills and
now we've got our recipe for skills now
this says that you basically for every
level of emotion you add a skill or if
every level of emotion including zero
you use a skill so a couple of things so
at zero we need to be using one skill I
bet you can figure out that it's
probably clearer picture that we need to
be doing all the time and then and then
at a five you need six skills and so we
talked about is stringing together two
nume activities because you notice that
the um categories said there are only
five skills in the first category so if
you're at a very high level we're saying
and need to double up on one of those in
the first category okay so this is kind
of what it looks like this is one of
those little chains and there's no
particular it's just just a visual on it
so the dotted line represents a more
dysregulated response of you know a very
sharp quick this is like for a level a
very high level stressor where it goes
up and then you see that slow return to
baseline
up top on the jiggy jag and then sort of
that exacerbation sometimes when they
start coming down and go back up with
what you might think would be a
relatively small stressor and so the
alternative is to become aware of the
emotion sort of early in the experience
as early as possible in the experience
and you can see the pictures here
represent clear picture on track
thinking on track action in this
situation the person used the safety
plan and a new me activity and the new
me activities they chose were video
games and listening to music and the
point is really to kind of bend the top
of that emotion a little bit you know to
help them tolerate the distress without
bumping out and then once you sort of
get regularly then you're doing that
when your emotion changes again or when
a situation or your your levels change
you start back again with clear picture
and on track thinking and on track
action and so really it's like this for
evolving skill use throughout the day
when people first start and group it's
kind of interesting because I'll say
I'll say something like so how is clear
picked how many times should use clear
picture this week and sort of some
people the rookies will say or used it
twice and then rinse I'm going to look
at me like Julie how can I count as a
clear picture I did it like thousands of
times this week and it's been really I
can you know it's like re I'm strategy
key and so that's really true is that
they're using it all the time and it
really gets integrated into their
experience okay all right so we have
okay so let's so that's sort of the
overview now let's take a couple of
minutes and start looking at each one of
the skills I can't guarantee him and get
all through these because I am just
horrible time manager but if you don't
get all the way through I'm really sorry
okay so here the six clear picture do's
and I know it starts with a breath but
it's never really the first one because
usually it's some other event whether
it's something in the environment so
you're getting aware of your
surroundings first maybe it's a feeling
that that sort of triggers the need to
use skills it might be a thought that
pops in it might be an urge but what I
try to help the folks talk about is that
it's important to then follow that with
the
if possible so so it would be maybe a
feeling than going to the breath notice
the thoughts so we're looking at is
really trying to expand awareness
through the sort of structured way of
the of the current moment okay one of
the things too is the breath is so
critical and it's you know we talked
about the macro fishing it really is
that trigger that cue that starts the
whole process physiologically it already
it also sort of starts the process of
relaxation or at least it's really about
focus it's not necessarily relaxation
that's actually focusing attention and
emotional deployment on the breath kind
of moving into the belly area if
possible or wherever you're you're
focusing attention whether it's on the
nose of the chest or the belly but it's
at attentional deployment to start
bringing awareness to their internal
experience
the other cool thing is that doing the
breath it really does trigger that sort
of sense of centeredness and that sense
of internal sort of wisdom and capacity
and that sense of sort of connection
that touchy-feely connection to your
self-concept and it's really nice that
so so it's really a concrete activity
that they can do that starts this
important process okay so if somebody
says to me oh you know I'm really I'm
really mad I'm just want to punch him in
the face my comment is gonna be good
clear picture it's very good you know
I'm happy with that
that's really actually a really
excellent clear picture I mean I've done
it yet you know but they're they're
telling me what's going on and so I
think sometimes if somebody were to walk
up to somebody and say that it'd be
don't do that you know so that's sort of
one of the differences with clear
picture it's about observing and
describing what's there and expanding
that capacity another thing is like the
feelings rating scale the clients will
say to me I'm gonna I'm at a 10 like
alright so that's pretty good seems like
you're pretty upset I said are you
hurting yourself oh they're property
well no I said well then I'm a [ __ ]
okay right there
right there's a nice little
de-escalation just a really simple
intervention they're really kind of mad
they're two four all right that's true I
mean if that's what it looks like it's
really true it's not to invalidate cuz
it feels like a ten it really does feel
like a ten and it's kind of this at
reframing their well actually I'm
enduring this and I'm not beating you up
and hurting myself and I am actually
sustaining this sort of for and to be
honest with you they're probably
technically at a three at that point
because they're able to have a
reciprocal conversation where they're
listening and I'm talking and they're
probably feeling miserable but at a
three okay all right so we talked a
little bit about the feelings rating
there and getting a sense of you know
part of as they go through I didn't
really talk about it too much but so
part of this is to part of clear picture
when they do do the breath let's make
sure there are three components of clear
picture that are really important in
your coaching I mean it's all important
but if you had to do a quick and dirty
on it you'd want to make sure that you
we coach the breath and we want to make
sure we get the feelings rating why do
you think that's important why do we
need to get a feelings rating when we're
coaching this good answer it tells us
why what category what category to use
remember so it's really important that
so if I know that I'm at a level two you
can look at your handout and cheat
that's really fine it's a worked example
so if I'm at a level two what skills can
I use all of them very good I can use
both categories I can talk about
contacts I can talk about people I can
talk about any and do problem solving
because I'm the level two why I tells me
something else to I'm at a level two I
can use all my skills which is really
really important information at the same
time it tells me how many I have to use
right because of my recipe I need to be
using at least three skills okay and
that's part of that understanding that
it's the idea of sort of a
responsibility to
multiple steps and that's and just
having people understand that it's not
like alright I did one skill now I can
put my feet up and not do anything else
today I'm it's started you know the
recipe kind of started along obviously
only time ago but I remember clients
coming to me and say Julie I took a
breath alright it's like I didn't want
to get into the math but it's like
one-sixth of one skill right so it's
just not enough okay okay great so
here's our transit so we have our
transition we notice the urge we're
gonna be checking it so here we go we
went over that a little bit with
checking it using the thumbs up thumbs
down and turning it and it's really
important to like the clients that we're
dealing with this sort of sense of
turning it it's almost like this gets
really rusty and to be on track
sometimes because they sort of have a
lot of off-track thoughts and a lot of
self devaluing thoughts and so these are
hard to mobilize sometimes but when they
say when they first start what I notice
is that it's mostly about sort of
consequences like if I do this bad
things will happen I'll get on
restriction or I won't be able to go in
a trip or something that and what
evolves later is more like well you know
if I do that it doesn't help me get to
my goals they become a little more
conceptual like that's really not who I
want to be but when we first start out I
have to say the the the turnit kind of
thoughts are generally about bad stuff
happening but you notice you know as
hard as it is to turn sometimes it's
like got a really but it's like like
very slippery on the downside and so
these old behaves old thoughts come back
really quickly so we have to do a lot of
turning just that they have a lot of
ingrained sort of thoughts
okay the last part of Ontrack thinking
is about making a plan that's sort of
thinking through the options that
they've got and so in that they're going
to be thinking about all right what acts
what skills can I ask
and you know doing how many do I need to
use although I think probably that the
recipe is a better retrospective tool
when you're doing solution and behavior
analysis because most of the skills
masters that I choose that we have they
understand that that recipe thing is
really just a the first step it's really
about using a lot of skills you use way
more than the recipe they use these long
long chains and not just two or three
because that's just not going to be as
effective as when you really pile up the
skills in a certain situation and so
they're out skilling a situation and
really slang it so that's they get
pretty excited about really cranking on
that and then they decide sort of which
you know so in high-risk situations if
they've got some danger they know the
safety plan new me activity is an
important thing you know if they're
having some distress about their plan or
something like or rules things like that
they're gonna be thinking
problem-solving but they're so P owed
about the rules that probably what's
going to happen is they'll have to do
safety plan new many activities till
they're in a good space and then get
some help and sort through sort of how
to do the problem solving you know
things like that that's the thinking is
sort of what skill is going to help them
get there get what they want and it's
really a dialogue I think that there's a
really important dialectical process
that goes on in group skills groups are
a blast they're easy to run at least the
folks with intellectual disabilities on
I do a transitional age youth group of
non-disabled people and adolescents and
that one's a little trickier but I
believe or not so a group runs really
really well and when people sort of have
the dialogue about what skills to use
and they're all debating and talking
about what skill and we talk about a
context and what skill was that well was
that this or was that that was it
getting her right I don't know I was
expressing myself you sure Julie was
that an Ontrack actually like these
dialogues are like very interesting sort
of dissections of situations and they
have a ball doing it and they get very
savvy at understanding the concepts in
context
okay so then we transition to entre so
here we are they're sort of on track
an off-track motif that we talked about
and it's really important about staying
on track but honestly how much do we
stay on track really right we're not on
track all that much so just being
realistic about the idea that that's
slipperiness I mean we're all pretty
slippery with our goals and sort of
understanding that tenuous relationship
that we have that changing relationship
and one of the speakers talked about
that this morning sort of about being
being realistic about sort of our
capacity is forced assistant or
sustainability on goals is important so
really equally important is the idea of
getting back on track sort of once you
fall off and so the main concept of an
on track action is really that first
action that you take in a situation so
if I feel like I want to throw the
clicker at my house mate because he's
being incredibly annoying my on track
action would probably be a safety plan
at that point because I'm up at about a
level four and my on track action would
probably be taking the clicker that's in
my hand and putting it down on the
coffee table okay so that's our just an
example of that first thing you do does
having some off on track thinking isn't
isn't the end of it you need to be
actually executing that on track action
but there are also a few other concepts
that are important in this skill so the
idea of switching tracks is helpful this
folks get kind of problem focused or
they get kind of what you might call
stuck or off-track and so we talked
about is that attentional deployment or
actually behavioural change an
activation that needs to be shifting in
another direction we call switching
tracks the other one cool thing is
something called an on track action plan
and this is really sort of things that
people do proactively during the week
and during their day to help manage
their biology
you know it's things like balanced sleep
balance eating you know engaging in work
and balanced ways doing yoga or you know
all those things that you do to sort of
keep yourself sort of on track and so
when when disruption does come
from inside or out there in a little bit
better position to manage it they're
less vulnerable physically accepting the
situation is really hard and and
important to do sort of when you've
already done everything and that's a
tricky balance sometimes just making
sure that the helping the person
understand that they really can do
everything that doing everything they
can is really important to solve these
problems because it's really easy to get
disenchanted living in these systems
that are so how to describe it but for
folks not in a disabilities world it's
they're very challenging environments
that tend to be pretty entrenched and in
the way that they work and and so except
there are times like they have to deal
with being quick waiting they just wait
a lot more than we do they're like
waiting for vans they get right on vans
with people they don't even like they
got staff they can't stand I think
there's a lot of acceptance that goes on
as an intellectually disabled person and
so there are times and you just have to
coach on track action and except the
last one is letting go let it pass and
move on you know this gets into sort of
that time where you're saying all right
you know you know you've spent you know
we spend quite a lot of time and in the
moment with an with an either a thought
or a feeling or a situation like that
and it's sort of when you say to
yourself all right this is actually
causing me to increase my emotional
arousal versus decrease and I'm kind of
ready to bring that arousal level down
and so it's sort of that you know it's
that attentional deployment again sort
of our situation change to try to sort
of move into another direction okay
here's the on track action plan I just
love on track action plans these are
just things in the curriculum like that
it's all like is all this like things
are in work all the worksheets and you
can and then you can copy a copy right
you can copy them and then you can use
them in individual therapy like you know
that's kind of a fun activity just like
having people set up their on track
action plans
I like this clip art look at that little
guy I know I need to get a life don't I
but but that's a cool one don't you
think I love that little guy these guys
worries memories painful emotions look
at them all all right I just show that
just so you can see how cool it is all
right so here we go all right so you got
the three so we got our little triangle
which is our clear picture on track
thinking on track action right and then
the next sort of on track actions that
they can take at that point at any level
would be safety plan and Noomi
activities which we'll get to and then
if they're if they're below if they're
above a level three they don't have
access to these but if they're below
they can do problem-solving expressing
myself getting it right and relationship
care I'm just kind of visually helping
you get a little picture of that now
we're gonna watch a little video these
are my clients all the releases they
love this stuff it's on my website so I
think I hope you enjoy it now they're
yes Todd you're in the stage left is the
Savior
all right wait I'm gonna try this all on
my own all right there we go what it's
so close to just do it
so we don't have a lot of time and so
what I thought we could do oh very good
really quickly and like we have like
five minutes okay great skill number
four will do we can talk about the video
too after if you want
I never get tired of watch them because
I do all the video editing I just I love
it so so safety plan is skill number
four just amazed I'm gonna give you the
zip through really really quick on these
so it's just they learn how to rate
their risk unfortunately folks sometimes
over eight their risk being too high and
they get really avoidant or they under
rate and get in tough situations so
safety plan is really about having a
clear sense of what the actual risks are
different levels engaging thinking
talking and written safety plans
understanding that there are different
things you can do in low risk situations
it's it might be best to stay there and
really focus on what you're doing
instead of just bumping out of it and
being avoidant and so gauging when you
should stay and engage and do exposure
really to the situation instead of
escaping immediately is an important
thing to know in higher risks and folks
you know move proximity they move away
or leave the area so that's and here is
like one of the safety plans for example
that they would do like a written safety
plan everyone's favorite skill for the
most parts Noomi activities and these
are all the things you do during the day
that are just the activities day of
daily living
we break them down into four and I'm
sure this more but that focus Noomi
activities feel good distracting myself
and having fun really important
especially when folks are cognitively
and emotionally disregulated to have
focus activities to do that help with
cognitive regulation I think one of my
favorites is just a very simple like if
we're not there
somebody's getting dysregulated I'll
just do a simple card sort with them and
it's basically just shuffling a deck of
cards and kind of putting black and red
to start with because when they're
really ripped off right they're really
upset they're kind of slamming and they
put him in wrong color and the wrong
thing and so the pile is are going
everywhere and sort of slowly as they
get through it and I asked them to kind
of tidy up a little bit and they focus
and pretty soon you're going to have
they're able to do the black and the
black and the red and the red and it's
they're keeping it together and then
once they get through that we sort once
they're doing that effectively we go
into diamonds and hearts and spades and
clubs and that's a little bit more
differentiation there that they have to
do and so that's just kind of like a
tangible little trick that I like but
organizing cleaning and counting folding
just having a repertoire of these kind
of things whether it's a video game or
solitaire or folding clothes from your
laundry these guys have no money and so
it's you know you have to be pretty
creative with Noomi activities that
actually are fulfilling and interesting
and they also have a hard time engaging
in novel activities and what you think
might be a really reinforcing activity
you're like why are you not doing this
you're asking yourself but really that
hesitation and that sort of difficulty
with transitions as well as just you
know they're theirs they're just not
great sometimes it going out of their
comfort zone and so you have to do a lot
of work really reinforcing people to
take those on track actions to do
different Noomi activities to expand
those capacities feel good these are
sort of you know you know once the your
body is triggered trying to sort of
improve the sensory experience
you know calming yourself self soothing
distraction is important it's really
important to know when to distract and
when not to when you've done everything
you can you need to chill out then
distraction is a great thing if there's
a lot of things you can be doing at that
time and you need to be doing a safety
plan or some other activity or
responsibilities distractions not the
best thing
and so really gauging when to distract
and when not to so that you can modulate
your engagement
fun these guys and we people need to
have a lot of fun what time a quality of
life really want people to experience a
fulfilling you know human human
experience and so having a lot of
different fun activities is good am i
getting them oh I'm at zero okay guys
but that's the all the time skills and
check it out if you want to know more
about it sorry I couldn't get through it
all thank you hey stay up there please
we're gonna have let's um we have time
for questions and and and there may be
more things you want to share that can
come out in the questions the questions
are starting to roll in
okay
first easy question is can your
intervention be modified for use with
young children with or without PDD
pervasive developmental disorder people
my goal was to make this very accessible
and so I tried to put a lot of tools for
people like on my website really cheap
so that people can practice with it and
try it and I think there are a lot of
people sort of experimented with
different groups
I personally the only other group I run
which is a transitional age youth group
it's basically like taking all the
teaching strategies that I put in the
book and turning them upside down so I
think basically the teaching strategies
that are in the book it's in the
curriculum are you need to be tweaked
you can't follow the curriculum for
everybody it's really for this
population and so but if you alter the
strategies I think maybe I like
collaborating with teams you know they
have diverse populations I'd be willing
really like collaborating with people
that want to take it in a little
different direction and that way you can
keep kind of like what I did you know
you can keep adherence with the model at
the same time on that it sounds like
there's at least some people that would
like to contact you so you're open to
emailing and cell phone 5:08
it's all over the website - no I'm just
not three one seven two one one five
call me no I want to and if you use it
you know call me I like hearing about it
because I liked it we would come in
network I was like doing a conference a
couple weeks ago while ago and this guy
came up he's like I'm from speed and I'm
using the skill system I really love it
oh sorry I didn't do that accent right
but who's this really cool has the
program been used with behaviorally diss
controlled such as duly diagnosed young
adults yes we're doing it now it makes
me feel really old but yes they call me
call me on that kind of stuff where we
can really just kind of talk about how
to tweak it with the with that age group
we really we have to increase the
relevant context part of teaching really
getting that they have a very high
threat you need to make it relevant for
that group and so it really does change
they're not as sort of readily wanting
to to become regulated so helping
motivate them is a key part of it can't
be used with children down to what age
would you say young has a bit you know
does it use with children I don't know I
know that it's being used at Swansea
would school in Massachusetts they go
down at age 13 actually Arcadia children
his home in Rhode Island was using it
and those were those kids were like
eight nah but we're talking about I
don't have any data for that for sure
how can others such as caregivers help
use skills that's a great question
well it's a little bit challenging to
teach folks how to be skills coaches but
I would say that the the tools that are
available on the website for like 15
bucks you can get a CD that has the
whole summary on it and you could like
stick it in your car radio and listen to
it I think that's a nice tool the other
thing is online on my website there's
competency evaluations that are free and
so you can you can listen to that and
then you can go online and take your
quiz
there's also a skills coaches CD and
there's also skills coaches exam and so
you know for relatively small resources
you can get the information this one may
relate to what you're just saying it's
about dealing with follow-through
between therapy sessions if there's a
substantial intellectual disability so
that things may get lost when they walk
out the door how do you effectively deal
with DBT we do phone skills coaching so
that's a really important part of what
what we do and and that really helps
with integration and generalization of
the skills and like I said we do really
try to teach teams but it's hard staff
really are the people in these
environments are not paid very much and
they have a few resources around
training opportunities and it's not
complicated but it's a little bit common
so a lot less complicated than DBT but
even this is really hard for a staff
member to understand and understand the
nuances of coaching because it's not
just the skills it's about that
relationship it's about its you know
being able to respect their autonomy
during the whole intervention can the
system be used with nonverbal
individuals that's a good question I
think I think it helps staff in that
when staff kind of understand sort of
some basic concepts then it can help
them regulate themselves helping them be
more effective and not acting
dysregulated ways you know basically
sort of not getting people you know to
do complicated things when they're
already aroused that's another thing
I've there are teams doing that and and
it's one of those things where I'd like
to collaborate and just talk about ways
that it could be would you highlight any
skill system implications limitations
with respect to TBI and then also
dissociation yeah it's a good question I
know Ivy Street School in Massachusetts
is a TBI program and they're using
and I haven't been in touch with them
since some of the new materials got out
so I think this might be some drift of
there but I I'm sorry I don't really I
mean obviously some of the folks I deal
with have TBI and so I think that I
think the the structure of it the
infrastructure we talk you know Anthony
was talking about sort of memory you
know aids and I think that the whole
thing functions like a template or a
prosthetic for people and so it allows
them to be more oriented when they're
disoriented and then the contextual
learning that goes on in group helps
more put more fat on those bones or more
muscles on those bones and so the over
learning of it and then putting it in
context for all the people suddenly the
arborizations really going crazy and it
really makes it more automated another
one with populations has been used with
in correctional institutes um a lot of
the folks that we deal with have
sexually dangerous behaviors so it
really was developed to help people that
have ingrained patterns of that are that
are really sexually problematic and so I
think it's a great application there
it's very heavy on safety planning in
some ways and I have a lot of that kind
of material if anybody is working in
Corrections Kokomo Indiana right now has
a Samsa grant for an implementation in a
hospital that was just reopen and
they're looking at shifting it also from
the outpatient and hospital setting into
the back into the correction setting
because a lot of people are coming from
corrections to the mental health center
and so they're taking it back to help
with the transition out so yeah it's
definitely and actually I think Robin
McCann one of the other trainers is
using it in Colorado as well given that
individuals with intellectual
disabilities are are three to four times
more likely to experience abuse how do
you help clients learn when resistance
rather than acceptance is appropriate
yeah I think that's all part of clear
picture understanding you know that's
why the system is really important and
under in the dialogue in skills training
it's not like a class it's it's like a
group really when you're there you're
talking to people about the nuances of
situations and I'm not
you could pick it up from the video but
the clients are fairly savvy and have a
lot of awareness and I think that those
are those conversations where they're
able to sort of make that dialectical
synthesis where they're able to sort of
bring together the polarization and I
know that I don't this is anecdotal but
you know people with disabilities have
really seen as having black and white
thinking well I find that with skills
training and I'm not saying it's a magic
thing or anything but with the the
training process you can really see
people able to see the gray and things
but it's just taking the time and having
the venue to do it in and people that
are listening in a way that can hear
people and so when they're able to be
regulated and they have a cohort that
are all having this conversation it's
amazing how sort of much less
polarization there is and more synthesis
there is this may be a follow-up to to
that how did you get your clients to the
place that they understand and accept
acceptance everyone hates acceptance
don't we all
it's a process you know I don't say
everybody is fantastic at acceptance I
think it's I think you know we probably
get beat down to acceptance in some ways
you know if it's a dialogue I sort of
knowing what's going to work and and
understanding through trial and error
sort of right you know I've done what I
can and and then sort of regrouping it's
not static no no this is static you know
it's like if it doesn't work today we
can reevaluate it we didn't get to
problem solving but that's about like
making plan a B and C you really want to
really want to get to sort of be a top
reach and then sort of the middle and
the bottom you don't want to we've got
to be really flexible and shoot for
things so what I would say is try
something else in that vicinity all
right and there and then the last ones
were compliments on your on your
presentation and also again about
contacting you which I'm going to direct
people to your website which is in the
materials it's just WWE skill system
comm and I'm like the webmaster so be
nice about the site it's not very fancy
okay I'm the social worker I know and
I'm like film editor you know it's like
had somebody had some none of it
particularly fantastic but it kind of
helps bring it to you know when I get
clothes from Alaska saying I've got
these people I've got no money my
program has no money and we've got these
disabled people in the boonies of you
know Ontario Northern Ontario that you
know and so it's just you know pulls it
those social worker heartstrings and so
I just want to get it all so they can
get it really cheap and easy and free as
much as possible okay thank you very
much